relations because of the threat of for
the russian air strikes and i think
because there is a an awareness that the
fighting continues on the southern and
eastern front lines uh and inevitably
today more people will lose their lives
instead we've moved down to khrushchev
which is the main
street that runs through the center of
kiev and olds of soviet wide style
boulevard that has been turned now into
uh this kind of
monument if i can put it like that for
destroyed russian military hardware look
at the
bullet holes on this one for example a
massive hole blown out of the side of it
you can see in some of the tracks as
well
the cloid mud from where many of these
vehicles you'll remember a number of
months ago got stuck in that infamous
column outside of kiev as they tried to
advance on the capital of course
president putin had planned that they
would take this capital city within days
president putin is a leader who likes a
military parade he would have had
visions of russian military hardware
driving up here in victory that is not
the case this is testament to the
failure of the russian war effort to try
and not only capture the capital city of
kiev but to try and take ukraine instead
they find themselves bogged down in a
conflict that's now run for six months
and will run for much longer the front
lines are moving by a matter of meters
that's it at the moment this is also
testament to the ukrainian resistance
against the russian invasion and that is
why today albeit that celebrations have
been cancelled official celebrations
have been cancelled thousands of
residents of kiev are coming down to
take photos down here many of them are
wearing the national dress of ukraine
and of course they will be
very aware of what is going on
in the east and on the south and the
sacrifice that is being made not just by
soldiers but by thousands and thousands
civilians who are dying in this conflict